-Welcome back!
-Thank you! Hi!
-I am thrilled to have you here.
Congrats.
This -- Your year started
with this show
being released on Netflix.
-It sure did.
-You had to do a lot of presser
on the heels of New Year's.
Are you exhausted?
-I'm a little bit tired,
but it's unrelated to the press,
which is totally fine.
-Okay.
-It is dog-related.
-It's dog-related.
He is the famous dad
of Frisbee the dog.
-Yeah.
-And some kids,
but, also, Frisbee.
-Yeah.
-And I'm sure
you guys have dogs.
So, the other night, I finished
doing some talk shows,
early mornings, et cetera --
nothing anyone
should feel bad for me about.
It's all --
I'm very lucky, et cetera.
So, I get in bed.
I'm like,
"It's gonna be an early night.
This is so great.
I'm gonna take Moxie the dog out
one last time."
10:00 -- I'm in bed.
About an hour and a half later,
I hear [growling]
And I look at her,
and she's, like,
this close to my face,
and her face says,
"I'm about to have diarrhea."
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, wow.
You know your dog well enough,
or was it that obvious?
-She was breathing in my face
in a way that was like,
"You have about 30 seconds..."
-Wow.
"...to get your
'you know what' together,
or mine is going to
get out of my body."
-[ Laughing ] Yeah.
-So...
-I wish I could say
this is a beautiful --
-Yeah, she's --
-For those --
just for, you know,
frame of reference, there.
-Ordinarily, I would never...
[ Audience awws ]
-Yeah.
-Yeah, that's Moxie.
I would never out her as being
something that poops, because...
-Yeah. And I'm assuming
you wouldn't make out with her
on diarrhea night.
-No, no.
I mean, almost.
-[ Laughing ] Yeah.
-It was --
She was so close to me.
It's as if that's what
she was trying to do, honestly.
-Yeah.
-So, we go downstairs.
Retainer's out.
Clothes over my...
-Yeah.
-You know, it's relevant.
-We're all, like,
just pretending
we don't wear, like,
a mouth guard.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-So, yeah,
I put clothes over the PJs,
'cause don't need
to horrify everyone.
And the retainer's out,
and I say hi.
We have a doorman.
I said hi to him.
I take Moxie out.
She does her business.
Um.
That was the beginning
of a very, very long night.
-Oh, yeah.
-I go back upstairs.
I dry off.
I get other clothes off.
Retainer's back in, obviously.
-[ Chuckles ]
-And get back in bed.
About an hour later...
[growling]
She wakes me up again.
So, every hour on the hour,
we went back downstairs.
By 4:00 a.m.,
I'm on my bed weeping...
-Yeah.
-...uncontrollably.
[ Audience awws ]
-I'm just so tired.
I was like, I'm being tortured
by tiny chunks of sleep.
And then, at some point, she --
I was, like, delirious.
And she --
It's like 4:30 in the morning.
She's having diarrhea
over a subway grate.
And I'm thinking,
"What's below a subway grate?"
[ Light laughter ]
-Yeah.
-Because, in my mind, they're in
the middle of the tracks.
But I also thought there was,
like, a 20% chance
I was gonna hear
a muffled, like, "Hey!"
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-So, I made a mental note
to check,
next time
I'm in the subway, like,
what's directly
under the subway grate.
-Yeah. Yeah.
-But, yeah, so then --
I just have so much respect
for people with actual babies
because this is what it's like.
You're up constantly.
-Yeah.
-And I had -- your wife
gives birth in lobbies.
-Yes, she does.
-And, you know,
fights human trafficking.
-Famously, yeah.
-Yeah, famously gives birth
in lobbies,
you know, for general people,
or just you guys.
-Yeah.
-Fights human trafficking,
et cetera.
My dog had diarrhea for one
night, and it nearly killed me.
-Yes.
[ Laughter ]
I will let you know --
and this is good --
the biggest ass ache
in my life right now
is still my dog.
-Oh!
-So, even with children
and everything --
-Well, 'cause I happen to know,
Frisbee is so small that,
on a couple of occasions,
Frisbee has been misplaced.
-Yes.
Frisbee will misplace herself.
Frisbee
will sometimes have diarrhea,
and she's so small that,
like, noise you made, the...
[ Growling ]
-Yeah.
-You don't hear that. Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
You just, like, wake up,
and you were like,
"You had diarrhea last night."
[ Laughter ]
I want to ask, you do not --
you do not have a child,
but you --
-I don't have a child.
-You're pregnant in this season
of "Lemony Snicket."
-I am, it was a -- yeah.
-And --
-You have
a wonderful prosthetic belly.
-It was a prosthetic.
Well, let me explain this photo.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, I don't know
if it requires an explanation,
but...
So, it's prosthetic,
meaning it's not real.
-Uh-huh.
-And it is --
it's very skin-like, though,
and it looks real.
People have thought
I was really pregnant on set.
I was doing all these stunts.
I was flying.
I was jumping into ice,
jumping out of ice --
all kinds of stuff.
And everyone was like, "Ohh,
what kind of 7-month-mom
is doing this stuff?"
[ Laughter ]
Anyway, it was fake.
And people would bump into me
and into it
and say,
"Oh, my God, I'm sorry."
And I was like,
"I can't feel it -- it's fine."
And they just
would give me this look of,
like, "Why can't you feel
your stomach?"
[ Laughter ]
But, anyway,
because I can't feel it,
I constantly
left my shirt up like that.
I don't know why.
But so, this is just --
this is just me in my trailer
going over my lines,
and my sister took this photo
because that's just -- that's,
like, how I spent my time,
is just belly out, pants down,
like, just...
[ Laughter ]
...living my life.
-The funny thing is,
I think that's the dream
of most pregnant women,
is to do that.
-Yes, Just let it out.
-And yet, you just were like,
"I'm gonna do it."
-Well, here's a new idea --
tell people it's a prosthetic.
-Yeah.
-You can get away with anything.
-Yeah, exactly, it's not real.
-Yeah. Yeah.
-And then, they'll -- yeah,
I think that's a good idea.
Did you ever think about wearing
it on the subway to get a seat?
Did you ever?
Be honest.
-I never did,
'cause it's very heavy.
-Yeah.
-And I loved being able
to take it off
at the end of the night.
And I was like -- my pregnant
friends would give anything
to be able to take it off
at the end of the night.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, exactly.
That would be a huge --
That's the thing --
That's the app
you should invent.
-That's -- That's horrifying.
-[ Laughing ] How...